hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime operor and with
blackbeard and the blackbeard pirates
making their big return in the one-piece
manga it is time to talk about
blackbeard's true power the secret that
he has been keeping from everyone for 40
years and why he may be the single
biggest threat to the entire world of
one piece which is something that shanks
has already warned us about blackbeard's
strange body structure the mysteries of
his devil fruit and his ability to
consume multiple devil fruits at once
are all related to his true identity as
the secret son of a legendary pirate and
the dark god of the underworld so let's
get into it you guys know the drill if
you enjoy our one piece videos and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment it helps us out a
lot and of course if you're new to the
channel take a moment to subscribe and
hit that notification bell it means a
lot before we get into it quick thank
you to tower of fantasy for sponsoring
this video tower of fantasy is a
beautiful shared open world mmorpg that
is available on pc and mobile the game
is heavily inspired by anime the voice
acting is amazing and i love the
post-apocalyptic sci-fi vibe i also
adore the graphics and gameplay i love
how free i am to move around inside the
world than have my own adventures and
thanks to the customization feature i
can be whoever i want to be and we have
breaking news the artificial island
expand is now available which means it's
time for a new journey explore
artificial island and unlock the new
home system to make your own unique home
on the island there is also a new map
you can exchange high value items and
you can discover new characters like the
lovely claudia she's strong she fights
for justice and let's be honest she's a
top tier waifu on top of that we now
have eight player raids players can form
a team of eight and challenge the
scarlet apophis and clone angels to win
special rewards this game is beautiful
and so much fun so check it out for
yourself and download tower fantasy now
to get 68 free draws max it is free it
is awesome and it helps the channel so
don't delay just click that top link in
the description and start playing the
game right now finally this video will
contain one piece manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned okay so back in chapter 956
blackbeard announced that he was about
to claim a certain prize before the navy
could get to it since that time we were
all speculating on what that prize could
be and our only clue was the fact that
blackbeard made this announcement soon
after the warlord system was officially
abolished in chapter
1059 we finally got the answer when it
was confirmed that blackbeard and the
blackbeard pirates had come after the
one and only boa hancock the blackbeard
pirates invaded amazon lily just as the
navy was already attacking the island
blackbeard seemed to be particularly
interested in boa's power and he refused
to allow the navy to get their hands on
it since we know that blackbeard has the
ability to steal the devil fruits of
others we know that he was trying to
steal boa's devil fruit the meromero
nomi
boa has the ability to turn anyone who
has thoughts of love or lost about her
to stone she can also turn parts of her
opponent's bodies to stone if she
touches them directly even if those
opponents don't have any lewd thoughts
about her boa also has the ability to
turn the victims of her petrification
back to normal if she chooses but
apparently at least according to what
boa says if she is killed then everyone
she has turned into stone who hasn't
been de-petrified will remain a stone
statue forever it is not immediately
evident why blackbeard is so interested
in stealing this particular devil fruit
power since no offense but no one in the
blackbeard pirate crew is good looking
enough to cause uncontrollable feelings
of love and lust in others okay maybe my
boy peachbeard but that's about it and
yeah i know i'm gonna have like two
katarina fanboys in the comments but no
guys no
that said there are some fan theories
out there that the merometer know me
only manifests as love and lust with boa
and that it might manifest as something
else with a different user so for
example maybe if blackbeard consumed the
fruit he could petrify everyone who was
afraid of him or who was angry at him
rather than people who are physically
attracted to him whatever the truth may
be blackbeard is clearly very interested
in this particular devil fruit so much
so that he is willing to brave his way
through the combat and take on not just
the kuja pirates but even the navy
itself in the end blackbeard failed to
take the meromero nomi because the dark
king silver's rayleigh intervened
blackbeard did apparently kidnap kobe
before departing amazon lilly but his
mission to steal boa's devil fruit
clearly failed now the reason why boa
her devil fruit and the gorgon sisters
are so interesting is the fact that they
were directly inspired by greek
mythology and in particular the myths
about the gorgons and medusa and the
more i think about it the more i
realized that many aspects of
blackbeard's character and his ultimate
master plan are also directly inspired
by greek mythology and i'm not the only
one who noticed this because you guys
have been also pointing this out in the
comments for quite a while if we look at
greek myths about the god of the
underworld hades who is also known as
pluton by the way as well as the hound
of hades cerberus we can actually learn
a lot about blackbeard's character his
ultimate master plan and how the one
piece story will finally end
as i said the gorgon sisters are a
direct reference to the gorgons in greek
mythology and to medusa and her two
sisters the gorgons were three powerful
creatures who were said to be sisters
there are various descriptions of
gorgons in different ancient roman and
greek sources but they are usually
described as three sisters who had hair
made of living poisonous snakes in the
earlier legends the gorgons were hideous
and in fact their faces were so
terrifying that gazing upon them would
instantly turn you to stone two of the
gorgon sisters named steno and euriale
were said to be immortal but the third
sister medusa was not the mythology
surrounding the gorgons changed over the
many centuries of greek history and in
newer versions of the story medusa was
actually said to be a beautiful woman
with stunning golden hair in fact she
was so beautiful that she seduced the
god of the sea poseidon and engaged in
relations with him inside a temple
dedicated to the goddess athena athena
was so enraged by this that she placed a
curse upon medusa and it was this curse
that turned her beautiful golden locks
of hair into venomous serpents the curse
also ensured that anyone who looked
directly at medusa's face would be
turned to stone in the most famous myth
about her medusa is killed by the hero
perseus after he uses the reflection on
his shield to determine her location
without needing to look at her there are
many interesting connections between the
gorgon sisters in one piece and the
gorgon sisters from greek mythology from
the fact that boa and her sisters
claimed that their devil fruit powers
were the result of a curse that was
placed on them as a result of killing a
gorgon to the fact that the cuja pirates
reside within and easily navigate
through the combat as we know the combat
is full of sea kings or neptunians
neptune being the roman name for
poseidon and of course the ancient
weapon poseidon is said to be the
sovereign of the sea kings so not only
does boa have medusa's power and
seductiveness but she also has a unique
connection to poseidon neptune by way of
the combat and blackbeard's interest in
boa also echoes some important elements
from greek mythology in some versions of
the myth the hero perseus the same hero
who killed medusa received a certain
helmet of invisibility when he went to
slay her this helmet is also known as
the helm of hades because it belonged to
the greek god of the underworld hades
and as the name suggests it has the
ability to turn the person wearing it
invisible blackbeard has already
successfully gained the power of
invisibility by stealing absalom's devil
fruit although the power was ultimately
given to shiryu and not to blackbeard
himself blackbeard's attempt to abduct
the beautiful boa is also reminiscent of
the abduction of persephone a beautiful
woman who became the wife of hades after
she was abducted by him from the human
world and taken into the underworld by
force in another myth hercules ventures
into the underworld where he sees the
gorgon medusa but his main quest is to
find the three-headed hellhound cerberus
and speaking of cerberus the comparison
between boa and medusa is merely
scratching the surface the comparisons
between blackbeard and the god of the
underworld hades as well as his
hellhound cerberus are even more glaring
and even more important to the story
hades is the god of the underworld and
the ruler of the dead and his powers are
associated not just with the underworld
but with the earth itself it is
important to remember that hades is not
like the devil in christianity and the
underworld in greek mythology is not
like the hell from the bible because of
that things like fertility and the
riches of the earth as well as natural
phenomena like earthquakes are all
associated with the god of the
underworld hades in fact hades is also
known by his other name pluton which is
believed to mean the giver of wealth the
greek word pluton is also where the
roman word pluto comes from now perhaps
the most obvious connection that we have
between blackbeard and the god of the
underworld hades are blackbeard's two
devil fruits the yami aminomi and the
guragura nomi i already mentioned that
in greek mythology hades is the god of
both the underworld and the earth itself
so he is associated both with darkness
and with earthquakes another key
connection comes from blackbeard's jolly
roger which mysteriously features three
different skulls the meaning of these
three skulls has been the subject of
much speculation among the fanbase and
this speculation has led to many very
fascinating theories probably the most
popular one is the theory that
blackbeard's jolly roger signifies the
fact that blackbeard has three different
personalities or perhaps even three
different souls residing within one body
this theory is consistent with marcos
comments that blackbeard has a strange
and unusual body with the rumor that
blackbeard never sleeps and with his
mysterious ability to use more than one
devil fruit as the theory goes
blackbeard has a strange body because it
is currently accommodating three
different souls blackbeard never sleeps
because he has three different personas
and when two of them are asleep the
third one simply takes over and they
keep switching so the body never sleeps
the reason why blackbeard is the only
known person with two devil fruits and
all of one piece is because each human
soul can only possess one devil fruit
but because blackbeard has multiple
souls he can presumably use multiple
devil fruits man so the reason why
blackbeard's jolly roger has three
different skulls is because each skull
represents one of his three souls slash
personalities this really is an
intriguing theory and i wouldn't be
surprised if something along these lines
turned out to be true i mean blackbeard
does seem to have some very distinct
aspects to his personality and i've seen
some of you guys in the comments talking
about the possibility that one of his
souls is actually the soul of rox d
zebic which was somehow imprinted upon
blackbeard's body during the god valley
incident when teach would have been only
two years old but the reason why i bring
this up is the possible connection
between blackbeard his three-headed
jolly roger and the three-headed hound
of hades the mythical creature who
guards the entrance to the underworld
cerberus cerberus is a multi-headed
dog-like creature whose main purpose is
to prevent the dead from attempting to
leave the underworld he is usually
described as having three heads a
serpent's tail and many snakes
protruding all over his body although
the three-headed version is the most
common today in some versions of the
myth he has 50 or even 100 heads he is
also said to have multiple backs three
tongues inside his mouth and eyes that
flash with fire he is a chimera a
creature composed of many animal forms
that have grown together into one it
should go without saying that cerberus
has a very strange body much like
blackbeard his three heads correspond to
blackbeard's three skulls and he has
been said to symbolize the corpse
consuming earth the endless void that in
the end consumes everything in that
sense cerberus is certainly similar to
blackbeard whose yamiyami nomi is the
embodiment of an all-consuming void so
the parallels between blackbeard and
hades and his servant cerberus are clear
but what does this actually mean for the
one piece story even though oda clearly
takes a lot of inspiration from various
myths from all over the world he doesn't
adapt them word for word so how much can
these mythological parallels actually
tell us about what is going to happen
next in the one piece story and how one
piece will ultimately end
one very interesting fact about cerberus
could be tied directly to the mysterious
connection between blackbeard and rox d
zebek i'm sure that everyone has heard
of the theory that blackbeard might be
the secret son of zebec and that he was
orphaned during the god valley incident
when he was only 2 years old many have
speculated that blackbeard wants revenge
for the death of his father and for the
fact that he had to live his entire life
as an orphan him naming his ship the
saber of zebek is a blatant clue that
blackbeard intends to finish what zebek
started 40 years earlier he plans to
carry out zebec's master plan of
overthrowing the world government and
becoming the king of the world if we
accept that blackbeard was in part
inspired by hades and cerberus from
greek mythology then who would be the
inspiration for zebic a good place to
start is the father of cerberus typhon
who is a monster god and the father of
all the monsters he was a fire breeding
chimera even more terrifying than
cerberus himself
gaia and tartarus created typhon in
order to defeat zeus and the olympian
gods after they overthrew gaia's
children the titans typhon was able to
easily overpower all the olympian gods
except for zeus zeus fought typhon but
he lost the first battle and typhon tore
off his tendons in the process as an
injured zeus went into hiding on mount
olympus hermes was able to use his speed
to get zeus his tendons back eventually
zeus was able to defeat typhon by
hurling hundreds of lightning bolts at
him and then he placed an entire
mountain on top of him in order to stop
him from escaping this is extremely
interesting to me because in greek
mythology you have the ancient gods the
titans being overthrown by the new
olympian gods during the divine war
known as the titanomachi kind of like
the war between the ancient kingdom and
the alliance that became the world
government in one piece then you have
typhon coming in to try to overthrow the
olympian gods kind of like zebek
declared war on the world government and
tried to overthrow them but ultimately
failed however
typhon did leave a legacy behind he is
the father of all the monsters just like
the remnants of zevek's crew the rox
pirates all became monsters in their own
right and if blackbeard is partially
inspired by cerberus then just like
typhon is the father of cerberus zebek
may be the father of blackbeard and just
like zebek tried to overthrow the world
government and become the king of the
world blackbeard is trying to achieve
the same goal for blackbeard it's not
about fame or pirate riches it's not
even about becoming the pirate king it's
all about avenging zebic overthrowing
the new gods and becoming the king of
the world blackbeard will bring the
powers of the underworld darkness and
earthquakes and monsters into the realm
of the gods just like typhon did when he
fought the gods of olympus and with the
recent reveal about imusama's true power
i think that the comparison of eem and
the world government to zeus and the
olympian gods makes even more sense
perhaps the ancient kingdom represents
the titans who were overthrown by the
world government and the world
government represents the new olympian
gods i mean marijua and the domain of
the gods are pretty freaking similar to
mount olympus in greek mythology they
are both abodes of the gods high up in
the sky and separate from the rest of
the world below and it's even been
stated that the celestial dragons
usurped this land from a previous group
of creatures who were once considered to
be gods the lunarians which is very
similar to the olympian gods usurping
the position of the older gods the
titans so what if the secret of the d
clan is that they are the direct
descendants of the old gods those who
ruled over the ancient kingdom before
they were overthrown by the new gods the
celestial dragons that is why the
members of the d-clan are the natural
enemies of the gods the natural enemies
of the celestial dragons and what if the
remaining members of the d-clan are
destined to try and overthrow the
celestial dragons just like typhon tried
to overthrow the olympian gods some
members of the d-clan will approach this
task from a noble and altruistic
position like for example luffy but
others like zebek and blackbeard will
approach it just like typhon did they
will become monsters who are willing to
do anything to take down the new gods
this is a battle between heaven and
earth between olympus and the underworld
and while luffy may want to liberate
everyone from the oppression of the
world government blackbeard wants to
overthrow the oppressors so that he can
take their place so that he can become
the new king of the world the new divine
ruler and this is exactly what we can
expect in the final saga of the one
piece story the d-clan is the natural
enemy of the new gods because they are
the descendants of the old gods the
rulers of the ancient kingdom the
remaining members of the d clan will
attempt to overthrow the world
government but while some like luffy
will try to do it for noble ends others
like blackbeard will try to do it for
their own sinister purposes and the
final battle in the story will not only
be the world government and the new
generation of rebels trying to overthrow
them but we will also see a battle
between the different factions within
the rebels themselves between the two
faces of the d-clan the noble and
altruistic luffy and the dark and
vengeful blackbeard let me know what you
guys think has blackbeard been hiding
the fact that he is the son of roxty
zevic and has he been plotting revenge
for his father's death for 40 years also
is the final struggle between the world
government and the d clan inspired by
the greatest struggle in greek mythology
the epic clash between the titans and
the gods of olympus definitely share
your thoughts down in the comments below
if you're looking for a video to watch
next check out our video that explains
every single non-canon devil fruit in
one piece link in the description if you
enjoy our one piece content and want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it helps us out a lot and if you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications subscribing and hitting
the notification bell may seem like a
little thing but it actually helps out a
lot on youtube you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror
thanks again to tower of fantasy for
sponsoring this video check them out
link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys